close game good work blood
sweat for that keep it going
all right boys me versus charlie if you don't
know we have played 12 games in the past the
record is six to nine 15 games that's bad math i
am up but the tale doesn't end there because he
beat me in the last paul champs in the finals of
the consolation bracket which was the most viewed
chess match of all time on a streaming service
at that point all right well here we are we have
the first game with ludwig as black and moist
as white we started off with e4 alright let's
see if ludwig has anything prepared oh maybe i
just got lucky ludwig's afk he overdosed come on
wait if he doesn't move it
give me that game aborted all
all right well uh children plug your ears yeah
but yeah it is that bad standard oh and he
pushes h3 which is what you were just saying
would be an issue because now um not only is
he not defending the knight on f3 a second
time or trying to put his king to safety but
he's baiting ludwig into making the correct
move but ludwig decides to recreate instead
into playing the right move is the funniest
line i have seen maybe i go on the offensive
oh there it is double attack
this piece oh and this piece
poggers
because i'm defended i didn't
realize that maybe the move
now is here god ludwig's stonks going up you
guys queen f1 would i just bring this over
and the crazy thing is if he takes on f3 and moist
decides to take his knight he has checkmate in two
um so i think we should take a listen in
on charlie here and see if he notices this
checkmate because it is really crucial he might
not be talking with one minute but um you guys can
can't imagine what's going on in his head
yes exactly behind that that totally relates
control over this but i can't
really capitalize on it now
okay so he needs to see that good he took back so
that is the move that he had to see in order to
survive and if queen takes the bishop then he can
recapture the knight and at least he has a chance
there even though his king is very naked there's
a lot of chances for both sides to make mistakes
especially as we are going to see a time scramble
remember there's only five seconds of increment
barely enough time to prevent yourself from
flagging these both of these players still
have to find very very good moves and i think he
has to play knight f3 here to fork the two rooks
otherwise rook h5 is gonna come and he's gonna
end up losing his knight on g5 so he has to be
willing to go for the trade or he could play
rook no not even rook g7 works no rookie
yeah richard seven there's actually d5 taking
away the square from the knight making sure the
knight can't go to e6 and protect that f3's they
only move oh no time ten seconds ten seconds oh no
okay nice collapse for ludwig in the chat that
was a good move to see with so little time
bringing the king in nice job
oh this simplification wow
wow that that deserves a clap honestly like it's
going to be a coupon game moist is up two pawns he
is going to be pushing the spawn um even there's
no still mate here right after king of a king of
six there is no still mate because ludwig still
has pawns to move um now it's just a matter of
finding the win and one of the easier ways i think
moyes has spotted it is to actually just bring his
king over to capture all of ludwig's pawns uh
yeah he could have taken and brought his king
but honestly with the time pressure he just
needs to see at some point you can either push
the pawn or take whatever he wants to go for he's
trying to go for that promotion and he has mates
in a few moves here yeah i mean ludwig's position
looked so promising when he played knight takes g4
but once again you have to remember if you don't
if you're sacrificing and you don't play the most
forcing moves or try to check your opponent within
the next couple of moves this is what might happen
uh you might end up in one of these worst end
games since you are down material and that was
part of the risk with the sake you know you still
get style points for going for it and it could
have worked out that's the cool thing with these
opposite side castles close game good work blood
i hate looking at analysis because they make me
feel like pure man i was playing perfect too in
that stretch up until here all right well we got
another game all right and we have a sicilian
by moist critical and uh ludwig is playing the
anti-sicilian line with c3 which i think is a
great line for beginners because it helps you
get both your pawns into the center and whoa he
is pushing all the way because moist misplayed a
little bit with g6 maybe he hurried a little bit
um i mean so technically this is playable
for black obviously ludwig's position
is already looking very good on move five
you know he's he's got the center pawns
he's got d5 and e4 push meanwhile moist has to
retreat his knight to b8 as i was saying that
he played knight to e5 and now he's going to
get him or his knight he was less prepared for
the sicilian than he was for the scandinavian i
feel like he played the scandinavian really well
that is quite an acute observation ludwig
okay great trade by ludwig
oh and he's just trading everything but oh
he blundered he could also take me actually
oh my god okay so bishop takes c3 is
a check or he might castle okay no
yeah he reserves the right to castle moyes played
that too fast yeah i didn't think that through
actually but i do like that i got the queen off
the board oh my god moist could have come back
it's it is still a move that charlie has to find
absolutely um so rook d7 charlie has to play it
but isn't there still rook c1 and rook c7 i
mean you can't really get away from that plan
this is true this is very true uh okay rick
takes e4 we do see d7 um charlie has to start
bringing his king okay well this move is
a bit unfortunate because you're actually
helping okay oh my god he just goes straight
for it i like i like this i like this
nice that was epic oh my god i love
this technique here check queen maybe
he's so calm cool calmly collected okay and i
like that moist critical is bringing his king
into the action the thing that he has going for
him is that at least he has these two past pawns
and look i'm not gonna say his chances are high
but he has a chance to try to do something if
ludwig somehow decides to move his night out of
the way for for content or something for content
quick critical should offer him 100 subs if
he moves his knight all the way to the other
side of the board that seems to motivate ludwig
unfortunately even the knight was all the way
on the other side of the board you still can't
push e2 because rook takes e2 is there okay well
oh that's true critical let's listen in on him
it sucks because he basically lost the game in
the first six moves or got a losing position
and he fought so hard but there just
wasn't enough firepower in his position
i know you guys it's it's tough
but um everybody has those days
sorry go ahead go ahead i was going to say on the
bright side a tie break from them which is going
to be super fun actually that's this is the wrong
way for a drone this is true and that tie breaker
is going to be very exciting as a reminder
the tiebreaker is in armageddon and if you
have never heard of that word before it is simply
white has five minutes black has four minutes but
black can either win or draw the game in order to
get the win yeah and uh those are always very fun
because it's going to have a decisive result
regardless i feel like you're setting me up
to say something i just didn't say anything i i
was actually just trying not to cut off charlie
um but the way we're gonna decide who gets white
and who gets black is whoever has the highest
accuracy score between the two of them is going
to get to pick which color they're playing with so
why is ludwig not mating criticism trying to
marinate him and enjoy the process a little
bit more he's playing with his food
here there was a mismating one however
pretty much anything in this position is
still winning so we're good all right okay
there is mating 2 with queen c3 king d1 and either
rook takes c1 or queen takes c1 so and he sees it
there you go well all right that does it the score
is tied all right and the clock has been adjusted
ludwig is playing the counter sicilian once again
let's see if moist critical is still going to
oh okay so he pushes his pawn to d5 right away
instead of what he played last game which was d6
how are you feeling about his opening nemo ah this
will be very interesting i think he's playing it
correctly this is the alpine so d5 is the correct
response and i wonder what line charlie has maybe
taken a look at during his break or maybe had
actually prepared beforehand and instead of just
rapidly moving g6 uh instead of d5 on move three
maybe he asked leaving this line before castle
okay good normal developing moves castle is
great critical castles as well and work oh this
is looking like game one bishop e3 this will
get intense really quick now i can take this
there's a threat here for sure oh
okay take now i'm playing knight c3
knight c3 great developing move uh critical has
to get out his bishop on f8 that's the theme we've
seen today with all of these scandinavian like
structures you haven't pushed your e or g pawn
so you do need to find a fast way to develop i i
would like to see critical try not to make the gap
of one minute even larger than it already is
but unfortunately that's where it's trending
two minutes 23 seconds he's now down two minutes
on ludwig and there's no increment that is huge
his queen is going to be trapped after the
knight moves even 92 a simple move like that the
queen cannot move uh if ludwig sees it i think
this is his game and he sees it this is brutal
that will be a pinned queen and there is
actually no way for black to get out of that pin
he should cry oh i didn't even notice it was a pin
whoops yeah even after bishop takes
f3 you can play queen takes f3
okay so rook oh no critical only gets a rook
for the queen and the bishop now ludwig is
just up way too much material this is feeling
very very doomed unfortunately for critical
yeah i mean he shouldn't give up of course 2
30 to 1 30. maybe he'll find some kind of crazy
perpetual but the hardest thing now is going to
be not getting his spirits down once you blunder
a queen in this situation you've almost given up
completely so if he can keep his head in the game
i'd say you know he still has like a 5 10
chance of come back which is better than nothing
of course i mean there's always a chance which is
why you should never resign um especially in blitz
when anything could happen right yeah in 1966
would have been so juicy but uh ludwig didn't
see it that's okay he has so many chances here
there's also like knight c6 there's just so many
oh 96 now especially just forking the king and
the rook and black cannot take back with a b pawn
because it was pinned but um honestly anything in
this position is pretty much winning for ludwig
and those are not words you want to hear if
you're with the black side of the pieces here
anything your opponent does is fine right yeah
pretty much it's just up way too much material
oh and and ludwig doesn't go for for the
knight c6 or knight a6 but he's playing quickly
he is slowly draining critical's
time here on top of the fact that
he has such a hard position to play
i like rookie 8 it's a good attempt
i like i do like this i mean just in case white
doesn't you know spot that the queen is under
attack however ludwig does see it plays queen
c2 um there's just so many great ideas in this
position for why to try to check mate critical uh
96 there's going to c5 just putting everything at
wow wow wow that's a good move and because
once his knight moves to c6 then his bishop
is going to be supporting his queen to get to
a7 if ludwig sees this uh he is just killing it
the cool thing is how much progress they've both
made since pogchamps won i think critical i mean
okay that's a good attempt this is a good attempt
knight to c6 with a check the knight d to c6 to be
precise because um you're just leaving your
fish you're opening up your bishop and now
it will be checkmate next move after b takes c6
or wow yep queen to a7 he didn't even flag him
he just beat him on the board that is brutal what
was it like being paired against each other ludwig
maybe you first uh i look i i want to play charlie
in one match in one match only that's the finals
everything else i uh don't i don't care to
play him uh more of a lover than a fighter
against him but uh you know i also did not
want to play el dorado so i uh definitely
wanted to win this one for that reason and uh
what about you charlie oh you well you called
us friends and now i can't talk because you've
made it more wholesome than i expected it to be
i didn't want to play ludwig because i thought he
was the strongest player here uh and he absolutely
slapped me in the last two games so i felt a full
fury from lud well to make you feel a little bit
better charlie we have this first game where you
beat him pulled up and this was a fun game dude
ready for the goddamn uh scandinavian i practiced
for the scandinavian but you didn't play it the
way i expected so i kind of just went off instinct
there raw primal i was gonna do this did you know
i was gonna do the scandy no no i had no idea
oh god yeah you crushed it i was like yeah he's
gonna have no clue what to do and you're just
making every correct move and then i forgot even
though i prepared the line halfway through and
i felt like you still knew what you were doing
uh i just had plans that didn't work out and
then i got lucky is really what happened there
yeah and you guys are showing this sack that i
did which i think was dumb i thought it'd just
be an equal trade and then apparently i'm supposed
to pin his knight to his queen and i don't think
there's a universe where i would have seen that uh
well we're going for checkmate here right was that
the plan yeah yeah yeah so you want me to rook
lift yeah i want you to recklessly okay let's just
back up a moment i'm one thousand rated i don't
rook lift i occasionally push it but you know
what rook lift is yeah cause pros do it i'm just
as sure what but you know it so you can do it too
oh you're you're more than that oh you're better
than that charlie stop you rook lift charlie
i have all the time i never stop rook lifting what
are you looking forward to in the championship
bracket i don't even know who i play apparently
you play dwight so i mean if you play logic you'll
play rain oh oh jesus okay christ oh all right i
think i'm on benji's side and you're on sardosh's
side and then xqc is also somewhere mixed in but
let's play sardoche first so we'll see about that
okay it'll be very poetic if you guys you know
claw your way through all these heavy opponents
only to meet for the final championship match i
think both of your fans would be really excited to
see that my dream we both meet in the finals yeah
that'd be so nice hunger games style we both eat
the blueberries we don't finish out the game it's
a draw we're both winners we leave hand in hand
never has another tournament it's
charity after all that could be huge
yeah it's chair what are they gonna do charlie
if we just play zero moves oh i don't know those
chest snobs would lose their mind in the
chat yeah yeah it's it and it's their fault
all right they did a game that you can tie in
that's the problem with chess that's why this
armageddon exists yeah chess.com listening right
now thinking how are we going to stop these two
from accomplishing that you can't stop us you can
only hope to contain us yeah you have to boost uh
uh sardoche with like the limitless drug
so they can attempt to beat charlie and me
yeah yeah that's what they'll have to do well
i love how supportive you two are of each other
and also just how close and head-to-head you've
been for so long thank you so much charlie and
ludwig for coming on for the interview
well played by both and i'm hoping both
of you are able to somehow meet and eat the
berries together at the end thank you so much